welcome to this video Yardbird again
Eric
lron let's
see yeah come on the nimzo doing I'm
doing going for something else want some
variety let's see what we get here the
classical
nimzo um yeah there are many lines here
and it's really like I don't know any of
them really good really
well but um me this this is this should
be possible let's
say um E3 or how is this
played or F3 even yeah I don't know
really yeah he's got C5 coming
is this
okay yeah he always has C5 okay not not
sure about
those precise moves I'm I'm really
behind in development which is
um never really a good idea against this
guy but
um it happened somehow
hey such a dangerous Dynamic
player you want
um your development to be
okay um yeah okay I I need I really need
to catch up here if he takes on
C4
um oh he
doesn't
okay
oh I forgot about this that he prepared
this with queen with the queen move as
well but okay it's maybe not that big of
a
deal A4 A5 is
also is also
something probably has to block
this with
A5
yeah he does not have to block this
but it's very much possible that he
will he
doesn't Okay I I definitely want this
in
okay well A6 is this this is kind of
kind of
useless he will he will play E4 that
that's
clear I
wonder yeah F3 is probably not really a
move
taking taking he will take with the c
Pawn that's that's really
useless
let's
see I I should have played Bishop
G3 yeah I don't know very difficult I
expect him to play E4 but this is of
course yeah
E4 he's threatening D3 then trapping my
Bishop but Rook e one it's not so clear
how bad this
is yeah it's a typically complicated
position against
him I really don't like my position that
much H maybe I should have thought about
taking now on D4 yeah simply because the
Knight is far away from C5
I bet
okay maybe Queen A3 and Knight B3 is an
idea you're really trying to attack me
here on the king side I
mean uh yeah maybe H5 stuff like
that
still don't believe that this is so
dangerous but maybe I'm
just just too optimistic
here or not evaluating this right H5 H3
H4 Bishop H2 Queen G5 Bishop F1 that's
still pretty
safe
okay and now Knight B3 was my
idea how are you protecting
that can take I can maybe take E3 in
this precise
moment
huh
maybe yeah Rook D7 is uh probably not
really
great he can take E3 probably should
take E3 I don't know I's got Knight E4
but Bishop D3 is kind of a self
pin
yeah I can take C5 it's not like to
crazy takes Bishop
takes or should I just take with the
pawn H not not
clear it's really not clear to me if I
take I'll take on F2 Bishop
takes yeah I cannot not evaluate it I'm
sorry this is just um check just very
very
tricky and I'm taking
this at the end I'm taking on
C5 I feel like my position is a little
bit shaky
but um yeah I'm I'm I'm going to drop
back I just need to avoid a Checkmate
yeah if I'm not getting checkmated my
Pawns will win this on the queen side
quite
clearly but it is dangerous
maybe Rook D2 is is his idea but I have
I have Queen E3
to to defend I
think
and C C6 is very substantial
threat I mean and the rook's hanging I
mean this
is okay Queen G3
right
taking D2 there was Knight
H3 n this this this should be this
should be winning
now
C6 yeah come on push
this not let's not
overthink everything now can take E5
to attack check the Knight as
well black resigns yeah I fended this
this
off very very complicated as usual this
this middle game position here was just
uh just super difficult to play I was
always thinking that he would play E4 at
some point but this is definitely um a
double edged decision anyway computer
likes white actually here I not much but
like 0.5
0.6 here yeah I wanted to have something
to attack so I went to attack
C5 and here
this yeah here the comp gives ed4 with a
big Edge
actually
it's possible if yeah I mean I have I
have coordinated now and and um have
good
safety something like this feels quite
yeah I have two Bishops and there's
nothing special happening those two
pawns will be a b
asset this was played and this also
gives gives me a a good Advantage a comp
actually wants to take here
yeah yeah maybe that was
Stronger plus
two probably this is stronger check this
seems to be uh very good as well
though yeah it's also 1.5 1.6 this kind
of stuff and here Bishop A7 but okay I
wanted Safety First protect stuff the
the pawns are are really enough to to to
save uh to to
win ah Rook D3 is a fantastic resource
given by the
computer
wow that would have been a
shocker so better is A6 winning or queen
C3 winning but he has Rook
D3
wow
here black even
wins which seems kind of crazy but it is
it is
happening with mate
coming I have to play
this
check